today on the matt walsh show we're told
that america is a systemically racist
country but the facts don't quite
support
that claim or in fact don't at all
support that claim
and today i want to talk about the one
fact that i think
most contradicts the systemic racism
theory we're going to get into that
today also five headlines including the
left's freak out
because the federal government god
forbid has finally started to come down
on the antifa terrorists is finally
enforcing the law
but uh that's very scandalous and and
and horrifying in the media the media is
very upset about it as well so we'll
discuss that and in our daily
cancellation
we will talk about the story of a great
and loving
and dutiful father who uh beat the hell
out of his daughter's molester after
catching the guy in his daughter's room
after sneaking in a window
well now he is under arrest so we got to
talk about that today
as well but first i want to
talk with you a little bit about
internet freedom social media companies
get to decide what content is
suitable for the you know sensitive
snowflakes among us and censor whatever
they don't like
shouldn't here's what i the way i look
at it shouldn't you be the one to decide
what you want to read or to watch and
not them shouldn't you get to
get to make that choice for yourself
well here's one thing you can control
their access to your data and for that
i use expressvpn see the problem with
the big tech companies is that
not only do they censor what you read
but on top of that
they're tracking what you do online so
they're you know they're keeping tabs on
you they're deciding everything that you
see
they're keeping tabs on you on top of it
they track what you're searching for the
videos you watch
everything you click as far as i'm
concerned they have no they have no
right to the information it's none of
their business
they use this data to serve you ads and
can match your activity
to your offline identity using your
device's unique ip address
when i use expressvpn these tech
companies can't see my ip address at all
my identity is masked anonymized by a
secure vpn
server plus expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your data to protect you from hackers
and internet bad guys
does it sound complicated it's not i
promise expressvpn software just takes
one minute to set up on your computer
and you're protected they do all the
rest so um you know i've been using this
for a long time and i think that this is
it's just there's no reason not to use
it it's almost irresponsible not to have
something protecting you if you're on
the internet all the time as we all are
so why give these tech companies a free
license to know everything about you
and then turn around and sell off your
information
it's time to take back your privacy at
expressvpn.com
walsh by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra three months of
expressvpn service for free and who
doesn't like to save money
i think we all do again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
walsh expressvpn.com walls to protect
your data today now i want to talk about
the idea
that america systemically raises
currently systemically racist
there's no doubt of course that america
was
at a time systemically raised it's just
like every country on earth has been at
a time systemically racist
um racism was the rule
across the entire country rather across
the entire world
for thousands of years and many
countries
currently still are systemically racist
the claim from the left
is not just that we were systemically
racist
but that we are right now today and that
the problem is not
just the legacy of slavery or jim crow
obvious examples of actual systemic
racism which thankfully are in the past
but the claim is that there is still
systemic racism today
and that isn't it it is in fact an
extremely significant problem
and it's so significant that as ilhan
omar said we played the video a few days
ago
we have to dismantle our whole economy
and political system and society
to rid ourselves of it the question
though is whether there's
evidence for this current scourge called
systemic racism i know evidence is
treated as a
as a mere technicality these days but
it really does matter because evidence
is all about you you believe something
well when i ask for evidence of of that
belief that's not a technicality
it's not splitting hairs it's not being
pedantic
what i'm really saying is oh why do you
believe that
do you have a reason if you have no
evidence then that means you have
literally no reason to believe what you
believe
which means you shouldn't believe it if
there's no reason to now remember
the fact that black americans as a
percentage
suffer more from poverty crime and so on
is not itself proof of systemic racism
because those are the things that
systemic racism is supposed to explain
so in other words we see the struggles
faced by the black community everyone
sees them
there's no denying that the question is
why are those things happening
and the explanation we're given is
systemic racism which means that to
prove systemic racism
to prove that it's true you need to do
something other than
simply point back to the things you're
explaining
it's the same with police shootings okay
there's there's there's
no doubt that a higher percentage of
black men are killed by cops
than white men or white people in
general
that in itself is not proof of racism
racism is the explanation we are given
for that fact but when i ask
how do you know that racism is the cause
you can't just
repeat the data point um that racism is
meant to explain in the first place
so this is a simple rule of logic and as
it happens when it comes to police
shootings
what you really have to look at is not
the overall raw
number of white versus black people shot
by cops in that case is actually more
white people than black people
you also can't look at the overall
percentage of black first white
people shot by cops that tells us
nothing because if say
black men committed a disproportionate
amount of violent crime which they do
then that's going to puff up those
percentages so
what we need to know is of
the black first white people arrested by
police that's the group we need to look
at
are either of those groups the arrested
groups
substantially more likely to be killed
in the process and the answer is no
so when you when you isolate it and you
actually look at the groups of both
races
arrested by cops there is not a
substantial
substantially greater likelihood that a
black person is going to die in the
process
um and that you know and that by the way
it's a little bit of a sidetrack here
we'll get back to systemic racism in a
second but
you often hear because a a greater a
greater percentage of black
men are killed by cops than white men
overall
as i said that doesn't tell you anything
but
the way that that's reported by the
media what they'll say is they'll say
something like
black men are two times as likely or you
know three times as likely to be shot
and killed by cops as white men that
that's not true
that doesn't make any sense you can't
just look at the overall percentages and
say and then and then say of every
individual
black man that he's you know twice as
likely to be killed by cops
because there are a lot of other things
that go into
your likelihood of being killed by cops
so a black man who's never arrested by
cops
or doesn't commit any crime there is
virtually a
zero percent chance that he's gonna be
killed by cops
we do hear of cases of someone just in
their home cops bust in and kill them
horrible horribly unjust everyone is
against that everyone is
is in favor of accountability in those
cases i know i am and i talk about those
cases when they happen but
those are exceedingly rare in almost
every single case of someone being
killed by cops
it's in the process of an arrest after
they've committed some kind of crime it
doesn't mean that the shooting is always
justified a lot of times the shooting is
because the police are responding to
fatal to uh lethal aggression on the
other side but
that's that's the point so if if you're
a black man or white man or
or asian man hispanic man who doesn't
commit any crimes
your likelihood is pretty much zero
it's not the same for everybody
um you know it would be kind of like if
i if you looked at
the overall numbers of uh of
of you know people of a certain race
who are convicted as sex offenders
and then we were to say uh you know of
everybody in that race you have a
whatever percent chance of being
convicted as a sex offender
well well no that's that's because
your your chance of being convicted as a
sex offender is
exponentially greater if you actually
are one if you if you don't get any sex
commit any sex offenses your chances of
being convicted as one
are almost zero there's still a chance
of being falsely convicted that does
happen
but the vast majority of people
convicted actually did
do it it's not like the vast majority
are innocent
so you know that's why you have to be
careful with the way these things are
phrased by the media oftentimes
because the way that they want to make
it seem as though
cops are just the reason they phrase it
like that
you know every black man has a whatever
percent chance of dying at the heads of
cops
they want to meet make it seem as though
cops are just
randomly walking up to people on the
street and killing them and that is
not happening that's just not happening
okay so back to systemic racism
what i want to do here is offer a data
point or a set of data points that while
they may not on their own disprove
systemic racism they do contradict the
systemic racism claim in a rather
startling and severe
sort of way i think what we have here is
an extremely
significant strike against systemic
racism
and it's worth looking at that and
thinking about it
now a very big problem okay for those
who
promote the systemic racism theory
is the story and experience of black
immigrants
in the united states if our country is
systemically racist
and it is structured to keep minorities
down if our if ours if our if our system
is inherently one that promotes and is
fueled by
white supremacism which is what we're
told you would expect
immigrants to do very poorly and in
particular black immigrants do worst of
all
that's not the case so let's look at a
few things here
um starting with this the share and this
is from pew
the share of black immigrants who live
below the poverty line
you see the graph there only four points
higher than the general u.s population
college degree one-third of a college
degree
nearly on par with the general
population household income
is lower than the general population but
not substantially lower
and then you notice how immigrants from
south america actually have a higher
household income
than the general population and this
year this uh
passage is from the site called a cycle
called courthousenews.com
says the income growth for female black
immigrants specifically female black
immigrants is outpacing both black and
white women born in the u.s
certainly not what you would expect from
a country that is
we're told inherently racist and sexist
patriarchal and and racist on top of it
in fact whatever marker you look at
whatever point you analyze
you see that black immigrants do pretty
well in this country
which is a great thing
now what do you expect though in
allegedly racist country why is that
well let me submit one possible
explanation
you find it here back with pew um
their statistics you see 50 of black
immigrants live in a married
two-parent household or at least a
married couple household
the number for black americans who are
born in the u.s
uh you know in black americans who lag
behind black immigrants in nearly every
category
the number there is 36
and so you have 50 verse 36 percent
pretty significant difference there in
fact what you notice is that
the groups with the the highest
percentage of married households
always seem to do the best in every area
this might explain something else now
it's widely known and uh remarked upon
that asians generally and asian
immigrants
do extremely well in america even better
often than native born
white americans asian immigrants in
america are a
a a stunning success story
which again that on its own is not what
you would expect in a systemically
racist country
doesn't disprove it on its own but i
guess what i'm saying is
if you didn't know anything about
america
and i told you or blm told you that
america is a racist dystopia governed by
systemic white supremacism
and you heard that and then you were
asked
which group of people do you think is
most successful
in this racist dystopia you would say
well white people obviously if you then
found out that
asian people are most successful you'd
be pretty confused
that's just not what you would expect
based on what you were told
i think this might have something to do
for do with it uh from the national kids
count data center this is showing us
children who live in two parent
households
and it says asians 84
whites 77 77 black 37
and here they aren't separating black
immigrant and native born so that's why
the number's a little bit higher than
the one i quoted earlier
but still it's it's it's it's still
strikingly low
84 percent asian 77 white black 37
percent
that's a hell of a coincidence isn't it
there appears to be call me crazy
a direct correlation between success in
economic and education
and you know economics and educational
and in many other areas
and stability of the family
there really is a direct correlation
right down the line
there are no outliers
you know um there's no group as far as i
can tell
that throws everything for a loop by
half by you know
not having stable families yet
succeeding spectacularly
that doesn't exist all of the groups
that struggle in the area of maintaining
stable
families also struggle in every other
area
the groups that have more stable
families are more successful in every
area
there are no outliers
now there are many outliers in the
systemic racism
theory there are a lot of groups that
throw you for a loop
groups that aren't doing what you would
expect them to do
on the systemic racism theory like black
immigrants asians etc
but on the theory that the family is
what determines success
everything looks exactly exactly
as you would expect it to look
if i told you that america is not if you
didn't know anything about america
and i told you it's not a racist country
but it is a country probably like any
other country on earth
where um the fate of the family in a
given group is going to determine their
success rate in every other category
and then you looked at the data it would
look exactly
as you would expect it to look based on
what i told you
that just can't be a coincidence
correlation does not equal causation but
it can very strongly
point to causation and here i think it's
pointing with neon
signs and flashing bold letters and the
sign
says ifs it's the family stupid
it's about the family
so this is where we need to look this is
not acad this is not
you know merely academic
or about trying to deflect or change the
subject
no if we actually care about
black children growing up in the city um
if we actually care what happens to them
which i do i'm very skeptical that
anyone in black lives matter
gives the slightest dam
i care hopefully you care
well then we we we know that they're
that they're suffering that they're
facing a lot of disadvantages that's
that's clear
we have to accurately diagnose the
problem
the family might not be the only problem
might not explain everything it's not a
cure-all
okay you get plenty of people that grow
up in in in supposedly allegedly at
least on the on the outside
stable families and still you know
suffer greatly in life and and
and and you know and and don't succeed
uh by any of these
these measures so that does happen
but it seems very clear that that if you
want to give a kid the best
chance give them to give them the best
shot
at having a good life a successful life
um you got to give them two parents that
are married
in the same house
so we have to start there that has to be
the message
and that's an important message for
everybody because although i showed you
those numbers of
you know number of kids by race and
demographic living in two parent
households
we should also note that that percentage
is going down it's headed in the
opposite direction
for pretty much every group so it's
still
relatively high a white family 77
percent
relatively high but that still leaves a
quarter of
of white kids who don't have don't live
in houses with married
parents that's troubling
and as i said trending in the wrong
direction
so this should be the message to
everybody you want to give your kid the
best chance
get married and stay married
start with that that's our starting
point
once we've achieved that then we can
start talking about some of these other
things
the thing that threatens black children
in the city
um it's not the police it's not systemic
racism
it's not the the kkk okay it's not
neo-nazis prowling the streets
all 15 of them across the entire country
it's not them
it's that they are most of them vast
majority growing up in
in in households where they don't have
the stability of a married
married parents who are there in the
home seeing to their well-being
and oftentimes the parent of course
that's missing is the father
and as as we have discovered in modern
society turns out
fathers are not expendable
uh you can't just get rid of the father
and think that everything is going to
continue along as normal it's not
turns out fathers are really necessary
kids need them what do you know
okay we're gonna go to five headlines
[Music]
today's five headlines brought to you by
the benham brothers learn how to own a
business without it owning you get a 15
discount on the benham brothers new
course expert ownership
at benhambrothers.com walsh it's
benhambrothers.com
walsh so fox has decided that it will
keep nick cannon on board as host of the
masked singer um terribly stupid show by
the way
i i i i kept hearing about the show and
i sat down to watch it for about 10
minutes
and i i almost couldn't believe so
people are why
what is this why are people watching it
well i don't know why i continue to be
shocked by the
rampant stupidity of our culture but uh
so he's still gonna host the show
despite the fact that he said white
people are soulless evil sub-human
savages
not even in spite of that they're just
pretending it didn't happen
like just not acknowledging it like
everybody else pretending it didn't
happen
so canon as a consequence of making the
most racist comments we have heard
on a platform that size in a long time
lost his partnership with viacom uh
which which
actually he lost it not even because of
the white comments but because the
jewish comments
but still keeps his hosting gig on fox
has been offered other jobs
to replace viacom and by the way we can
be certain he'll be back with viacom
in no time i pretty much guarantee you
that what this means is that
just taking another example those kids
who are remember those kids at jimmy
john's who are
uh on on on film playing around with
with the the the dough for the bread
pretending it was a noose
those dumb kids faced worse consequences
and a greater backlash
than nick cannon a major ubiquitous
celebrity who caught an entire race of
people barbaric and subhuman
this is cancel culture if anyone's
wondering what cancer culture is
this is it right here cancel culture
this is an aspect of cancer culture that
isn't
acknowledged enough cancel culture is a
left-wing
phenomenon it is it is run by the left
it's what the left does we might as well
call it
we should just call it left wing cancel
culture or left wing culture left disc
whatever you want to call it
it is a left wing phenomenon
it's there is there is no cancel culture
against the left
if there was nick cannon would be
canceled
he's not even though he said the most
racist thing as i said
can you think of of an example of a
major celebrity
or even a not so major celebrity um
saying something that racist recently
that's the most racist thing we've heard
from someone
at that level in a very long time he's
not canceled
the jimmy johns people are why because
the left runs a cancer culture it's all
them
so when when uh people on the right or
anybody else tries to hold nick cannon
responsible hold him accountable for
being a
a raging bigot that's not cancel culture
you can't say oh i thought you were
against canceled culture i am
it's not cancer culture all i'm saying
is
he just stood up and announced that that
his entire white audience which which
which i i i'm guessing especially on the
masked singers most of his audience
are sub-human savages you should be
accountable for that's like that's not
cancelled culture
canceled culture is when the left goes
after some random
kids and tries to destroy their lives
for no reason that's cancelled culture
okay number two uh the squads ringo
ayano presley is back in the news
here's what she said at a um house
committee on oversight and reform
meeting here's what she had to say
here here is her theory on uh
the history and formation of the
american
police you know it's going to be pretty
good listen to this too many
black women and mothers surviving family
members have had to relive the trauma of
seeing their
their loved ones murdered and live
streamed on national television
the mothers of the movement have been
trying to tell us for generations
from mrs till to lucie macbeth to stop
murdering our children
we must listen we must center these
experiences in this moment
of truth telling and reckoning and while
juneteenth is meant to be a day of
celebration and a freedom and
emancipation
again we must take stock of this moment
and be sober about the work that lies
ahead mr crenshaw um
is it fair to say that the policing
system in our nation grew out of the
practice of capturing
and often murdering individuals trying
to escape from his
from slavery could you speak to his
our policing system and how you see that
influencing modern day policing
no ayana it would not be fair to say
um it's not fair to say because you just
made that up
on the spot just invented that the
police department was
formed based on retrieving
and killing slaves what
every civilization in history has had
some kind of law enforcement mechanism
this is not unique the fact that we have
police in this country
actually it's not unique the only
countries that don't you know the only
time you're not gonna find any sort of
law enforcement is in a failed state or
the worst third world
hell holes you can find where they have
no sort of infrastructure government
uh of any kind anywhere else if you have
a civilized society
um there's gonna be police so you just
but
that's what that's that's what we see
now um the left they just make up
just make up something no reason for
that just make it up no justification
off the top of her head why not number
three the media is having conviction
fits today because
uniden quote unquote unidentified
quote-unquote secret police
are arresting quote-unquote protesters
in quote-unquote unmarked vans
um we are told that this is the
heralding of a
new age of fascism and tyranny it's a
big deal it's
my god it's terrible we should all panic
the poor pro
the poor poor protesters look what's
happening to them
um what have they ever done these
protesters besides commit serious
felonies every night for the last two
months straight i mean besides that
what have they done nothing here's the
the footage that everyone is
panicking about today look at this what
are you doing
use your words what are you doing
use your words what are you doing
use your words
what is going on who are you where are
you nlg will get you out
what's your name tell us your name
what's your name okay you're fine we'll
get you out
bro we got you friend
we got you nlt
you just violated their rights
[Music]
you just violated their rights thanks
for keeping them
[Music]
use your words use your words
okay so they're they're resting an
antifa goon dressed in all black with a
helmet arresting
that person in front of a crowd on film
they're in uniform the uniforms say
police on them
what's the problem here i i don't what
are we worried about with this
is because they look scary is that the
problem
and since everyone's you know having uh
is very upset about the unmarked vehicle
since when
when is this a new concept why is
everyone freaking out that they used an
unmarked
cops use unmarked vehicles all the time
especially if they
don't want you to immediately know that
they're the police
there's no law saying that they have to
announce down the street
that they're the police there may be
times when the police don't want you to
know that the police are right there
so there's nothing new about the fact
that it's an unmarked van
cops use unmarked vehicles all the time
totally normal
and also necessary in some circumstances
they've got the thing says police what
do you want them to do are they supposed
to
stop and ask permission excuse me sir do
you mind if we arrest you
we were just we i don't we were just
stopping by
thought we'd arrest you you got time for
that now is it okay
oh no okay we'll stop back later oh you
don't you don't want you don't want us
to arrest you at all ever
okay well then forget about it never
mind you're good to go sorry
we apologize of course
you know i'm i'm being sarcastic that is
actually what the left wants
that is how they imagine policing and
how it should work if it works at all if
we have police at all that's how they
should do it
number four uh that was in portland this
also is important
here's another cop sharing his
experience with those lovely
anti-racist white antifa goons listen to
this
it says something when you're at a black
lives matter
protest you have more
minorities on the police side than you
have in a violent crowd
and you have white people screaming at
black
officers you have the biggest nose i've
ever
seen i got to see folks that
really do want change like the rest of
us that have been impacted by racism
and then i got to see those people get
faded out
by people that have no idea what racism
is all about never experienced racism
they don't even know that the tactics
that they are
using are the same tactics that were
used against
my people a lot of times someone of
color black hispanic
asian come up to the fence and directly
want to talk to me hey what do you think
about george floyd what do you think
about what happened about this
i go to the fence someone white comes up
f the police don't talk to him every
time i try to have a conversation with
someone that looks like me
so white comes up and blocks him and
tells him not to talk and then right
when i said that this white girl
popped right in front of her she said he
just said that was gonna happen i said
straight up i said you know i've been
called the n-word
she's been called the n word why are you
talking to me this way why do you feel
that
she can't speak for herself to me why is
it that you feel
you need to speak for her when we're
having a conversation
yeah i think i'll just let his testimony
speak for itself there but i think that
tells you
everything you need to know about antifa
if you didn't already know everything
you needed to know about it
five finally i i just need to read this
report to you this is from
nbc los angeles which is the local
affiliate where all of this is happening
so okay listen to this headline
officials warn residents that dangerous
sex offender
may be released into org county it says
orange county officials are warning
residents tuesday
that a dangerous sex offender who has
targeted young boys was due to be
released
and we're asking for the governor of
california to intervene early wednesday
costa mesta
costa mesa police tweeted that he had
indeed been released
but was not currently in the orange
orange county city
leaving many to wonder where he was
carrie j smith 59 years old
was set to be released from a state
hospital where he spent the last 20
years he was set to return to eldridge
county where he once lived at the
hospital neglected to renew
a hold july 11 2020.
orange county district attorney todd
spitzer and the board of supervisors
um made the plea tuesday to governor
gavin newsom
saying he's got to do something they
previously testified that he fantasized
about raping and killing boys this
according to the d.a statement
uh spitzer said the sexual predator has
repeatedly testified under oath
that he will reoffend if he is released
and we should believe him
in 2002 spitzer attempted to file 20
felony accounts of a lewd and lascivious
act with a minor against smith but the
statute's limitations had run out
um he was sent originally in 1999
to a to the state hospital after
his then wife revealed a letter that he
had written to a psychiatrist
where he describes his fantasies
about raping a seven-year-old boy
he also says that he molested 200 boys
and killed three
this is what this is what he testified
during multiple hearings
um he also reportedly likes to go by the
name mr
rtk which stands for rape torture kill
all right so you've got a man who
testifies to molesting hundreds of boys
promises that he will reoffend again he
is dangerous according to even himself
and he's being released into the he has
been released
and they don't know where he is
uh and so far the latest uh from the
latest i've seen anyway the governor of
california has not stepped in he's not
he's not i guess he's this is not on his
top top of his list of priorities i mean
this is a guy that is
going to hurt and probably kill
a young boy according to him and there's
no reason not to believe him
and uh he's out there currently so if
you live in southern california
that's what he looks like carrie j smith
okay we're going to move on to our daily
cancellation
before we do you know in the midst of
all this news ben shapiro
has a new book called how to destroy
america in three easy steps uh he has
looked into the future and when he was
writing this thing and uh it's it's come
to life all around us
very prescient book the book goes on
sale tuesday july 21st at 6 p.m eastern
3 pm pacific
he's gonna be doing a live virtual
signing on the day of release you can go
to dailywire.com
ben uh how to destroy america in three
easy steps
details the the different visions of
america the two
really broadly speaking the two
different visions of america
that we see playing out and the one that
is
right now great gaining ground so
quickly
how is it gaining ground why is it well
that's what ben talks about in the book
that's dailywire.com ben to order your
signed copy and join ben's live signing
on tuesday
july 21st okay now i uh
i want to get to our daily cancellation
i will be canceling
with great wrath and vengeance some of
the people involved
in this story watch a lot of dads might
say they do the same thing as this male
cassias did
when he found a grown man inside his 14
year old daughter's bedroom
and that is to beat that man bloody even
knocked out some teeth
but investigators say there's only so
much georgia law allows
and they say the dad crossed the line
that's forty one-year-old ismail casius
on the left and twenty-year-old
kiwantrezes humphreys on the right
investigators say the two men first met
early july 4th morning
in the bedroom of cassius's 14 year old
daughter
investigators say in a rage the dad
severely beat
and choked humphries even chipped and
knocked out some teeth
and if it had stopped there
investigators say the dad might not be
facing any charges
but they say ishmael casillas asked his
wife for a gun and they say after the 20
year old jumped out the bedroom window
the dad met him in the front yard and
continued the beating threatening his
life
and firing shots through the
neighborhood as the young man ran away
investigators say that is where cassias
crossed the line
there's a line that you know he can't
cross we can't cross
there's a stopping point when somebody
is no longer a threat to you
my advice would be let it go and contact
us and let us
handle it don't take it into your own
hands investigators have also charged
kiwantreze's humphries with child
molestation
they say he was in a relationship with
the 14 year old girl and climbed through
her bedroom window
investigators say humphries is known as
man man
because of his age and the girls they
are pursuing a sex crime investigation
and more charges are possible we've
gathered phone evidence from the
from the young lady the young man's
phone has been looked at
and those are things that we're still
looking into as to
possibly further further charges
the dad was taken into custody that
morning on july 4th
they say after identifying and locating
manman humphreys
he was taken into custody in putnam
county thursday night
okay now i hope it's already obvious to
you that i'm not ken cancelling the
father here
i i would build a statue to him if i
could i would build a statue electrify
it
covered in barbed wire maybe put trap
doors around the base of it so that if
you get too close you'll fall into a pit
of alligators
that's actually what i would like to do
with all statues if i was under my
regime that's what we'll be doing
but he is not canceled i'm i'm canceling
obviously the child molesting scumbag
that goes without saying
uh let's take a look at him again after
the beating that's what he looks like
so that's that's just a wonderful
heartwarming picture right there
um but also i'm canceling the local
authorities
for pressing charges now let's think
about this for a moment put yourself in
ishmael's shoes here the father
a man climbed into your window to molest
your daughter your adolescent daughter
you find her you find him in her room
i submit that there is essentially
nothing you can do
in that scenario that should land you in
prison
i mean you would have to go very very
very far
and get very creative in your response
to that situation to justify criminal
charges if they can be justified at all
on any level whatsoever
um this loving father did not go
overboard in the slightest bit he
whooped the guy's ass
of course any father worth a damn would
do that that's just standard operating
procedure you have to do that
the only bit the only sort of extra bit
of relish that he put on this particular
hot dog
was to tell his wife to go get the gun
which i love that by the way he told his
wife
i've always wanted to say how do you get
the shotgun i've always wanted to say
that
um and he said that to his wife and then
he fired some shots as the guy runs away
okay now the way that i read that and
hear that it seems like they were more
warning shots
than anything i believe the report said
that he fired the shots as the guy read
didn't even say that he fired them at
him
um so it seems more like warning shots
of hey this is what's going to happen if
you come back again type of thing
but either way listen this is a man who
broke into your home
to molest your daughter you don't know
if he has a gun on him
you don't know if he has a gun back at
his car um
if he stashed a gun outside you don't
know he might circle back and try to
hurt your daughter try to hurt
you you are perfectly justified as far
as i could tell
in treating him as a lethal threat even
as he runs away because
he might not really be running away he's
just running you don't know if he's
going away he's going to come back if
he's going to run around back
going to get a weapon i i think you're
justified in assuming
that he is a lethal threat the entire
time he's within your sights
as far as i'm concerned at least
those are the arguments that i would
accept
if i was on the jury um
i don't even know if what i'm saying is
legally valid by georgia state law
probably isn't i don't care
if i'm on that jury the dad's lawyer
could just offer that as a defense and
i'm going to quit or he could say that
um you know he was temporarily insane
with anger
um i'd accept that he could say he
tripped and fell and accidentally fired
the gun
i'd accept that argument too um he could
say that he thought the gun was a laser
tag gun
you know and i i would also you know he
thought he was playing laser tag
i'd take that defense that would be
convincing to me
or his entire defense could be your
honor
look uh listen
come on you know you understand
come on that could be his entire defense
i personally on the jury would find that
argument
probably most of all deeply compelling
and convincing
um or literally any other argument at
all the point is that
if you break into a man's house to
molest his daughter
you have just volunteered yourself
for some very unpleasant treatment you
have consented to it even if not
verbally you as the saying goes have
written a check
that your ass will now have to cash
so i say cheers to that great father for
doing his job
um this country would be in pretty good
shape if there were like 50 million more
dads
like that out there we were just talking
about we started the show talking about
the
importance of having dads in the home
well here's one of the reasons
protector of the family so i would uh
cheers to him and a a stern cancellation
to everyone involved
with arresting and charging him i i just
have to believe
especially in georgia there's just i i
have to believe there's no jury
i'd have to believe there's no jury in
america much less in georgia that we can
victim that is my hope and prayer
anyway we'll leave it there for the uh
for the week guys have a great weekend
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there